hey guys I did an opposing views on the
Israel Palestine conflict coming up now
where I speak to two people on each side
of a controversial issue first off I'm
not the person to go to to get wisdom on
this war my opinion shouldn't really
matter to people because I don't have
the historical knowledge needed to have
an intelligent perspective on what's
going on I know what I've read and seen
online but I don't know how skewed that
is in either direction or how much of it
is straight up propaganda just because I
have a platform or anyone has a platform
doesn't mean they're an expert on
whatever the newest topic is all I
really have to say is I don't trust the
mainstream media on anything so it's
hard to figure out what's going on a few
days ago a hospital was bombed in Gaza
and a lot of innocent people died
initially a bunch of media articles came
out saying it was Israel then a bunch of
media articles came out saying no it was
Hamas misfiring literally impossible to
know what's going on and if the media
has lied to us about everything else for
the last at minimum 5 years why are they
telling the truth now anyway either way
the situation is horrible people are
really hurting and very angry all over
the world I've experienced thousands of
actual threats in the last week from
people telling me I want babies dead
mostly from being my dad's daughter and
not listening to his actual perspective
on the war this is happening even though
I haven't commented on the topic at all
if you don't comment you get people
telling you you need to comment because
you have a platform if you do comment
you get told you don't know what you're
talking about and if you comment and
it's not what someone wants to hear then
you get told you should go to hell
anyway I have friends on both sides of
this and all I know for sure is it's
terribly sad uh I don't usually know
much about the opposing views episodes I
host which is why I find them
interesting although I had my suspicions
for the coid episode I believe
conversation and talking to people is
the only way to figure things out and I
wanted to know more about this horrible
conflict so I spoke with David brog who
gave his perspective on the Israel side
he spoke about the current and
historical events that led to this and I
spoke to Norman finlin on the
Palestinian side where he spoke about
the same events from a different
perspective I'd recommend listening to
both if you're interested in this
conflict Norman's conversation is right
after David's hope you guys are okay
this has been an insane couple of weeks
and I do hope it gets better soon
although that
seems naively optimistic uh life's
already so hard without multiple Wars
political instability and massive health
and mental health crises basically
worldwide uh obviously I'm grateful to
have never actually experienced War so
take it easy on yourselves and try not
to burden yourself with the news if you
can't handle it if the news is ruining
your life and there's really nothing you
can do about what you're seeing anyway
take a break get off of social media
don't let it impact your personal lives
and the lives of your family especially
if you can't do anything about it anyway
being educated ated about what's going
on in the world is one thing but
becoming angry and hateful because of
that and impacting the people around you
and yourselves negatively isn't good for
anyone social media can be horrible that
way and remember Tik Tok doesn't show
you the truth it shows you more of what
you already watch which is likely what
horrifies you right now you can easily
get into an algorithm and only see half
of a story because it thinks that's what
you want to see anyway here's the
episode apologies for the lengthy intro
and AP if I stumbled through questions
or didn't address things properly I
tried my best here's the
episode David brog welcome to the
podcast thanks so much for having meel
appreciate
it so I think we should get started by
can you can you give me a brief
background can be brief about What's led
up to the war today going back uh I mean
as far as you see fit whether that's
2000 years or back to the 40s whatever
you think explains it the
best sure sure um lot of history here
but I I I would I would actually go back
to the beginning of the Zionist project
in in in the late
1800s um Jews had been returning home to
their Homeland to the little piece of
God's green earth to to which they are
indigenous ever since the Roman Exile
began in 78
um but that return accelerated with the
birth of the Zionist movement in the
late 1800s and lots and and then when
the British conquered this territory
from the Ottoman Empire that return
accelerated early
on patterns were established that
continue to this day and the pattern was
as follows Jews wanting to build their
country in their Homeland to which
they're indigenous recognized that there
were other people living in this land
arabic speaking people living in this
land who had not yet identified
themselves as Arabs they had yet to
develop a national Consciousness but
that came in the early 1900s and then
later they they they developed a more
narrow National Consciousness they
started calling themselves Palestinians
but early on from day war the zionists
understood there were other people in
this land and so they said we need to
find a way to live with them and
accommodate them and so from Early Times
there was a the the Zionist movement
said we need to find a way to split the
land two people claiming the same land
with with powerful claims the only way
to piece is to split the land and and to
have two homelands for two
peoples from day one the Arabs of
palestin rejected that idea from day one
they said no there are not two Valley
claims to this land there's only one
valid claim our claim and so we see this
pattern and and to summarize for for EAS
a summary there are five points in
history I like to point to when an offer
was put on the table to split the land
to create a Jewish homeland and and a
Homeland for the Arabs of Palestine who
later called themselves Palestinians
1967 2000 and 2008 are the five main
examples each of these times the Jews of
Palestine later the Israelis said let's
split the land
the earliest offers were the Jews got
30% the Arabs Got
70% and each of these times the Arabs
Palestine later the Palestinians
rejected the offer when they rejected
the offer with words that was a good day
very often they rejected the offer with
violence and sustained violence that
took thousands of victims the the the
offer made in 2000 by prime minister
edun Barack to yaser Arafat of the PLO
to split the land have a Palestinian
State side by side with the Jewish
Israeli state was rejected not only in
word but in deed it started this violent
inat in which the Palestinian Authority
and Hamas and we're going to get to
Hamas in a second competed with each
other to see who could blow up more
Israelis and and this was the response
to an unprecedented offer by prime
minister Barack and so this is the
pattern the Palestinians since they
they're they're birth as a as a as a
people as a as a separate people have
only had three leaders the first leader
was the muy of Jerusalem who was their
leader before and during and after World
War II the Muti spent World War II in
Berlin sending out Nazi propaganda to
the Arab world and his main mission
while there was to plead with the Nazis
to please take the final
solution to the Jewish communities of
North Africa when they conquered North
Africa and then hopefully to Palestine
when they conquered pal
after him was yasar AR an unrepentant
terrorist whose final Act was to reject
peace and to engage in a sustained
terrorist campaign against the Israelis
and now
mmas um none of them ever recognized the
Jewish claim to the land therefore they
have to refuse they they cannot
acknowledge there was a Jewish temple in
Jerusalem they won't acknowledge that
Jewish connection they cannot
acknowledge that Jesus was Jewish
because that would be a Jewish
connection to this day they insist
that Jews are just European Interlopers
in their land they even reject the fact
that most Jews in Israel don't come from
Europe there are Jewish refugees from
mus the Muslim Middle East who were
thrown out of their homes after the
birth of Israel in
1948 so in this big background Hamas
comes to continue that tradition and
Hamas comes to
oppose violently any chance of Peace in
the region and to fulfill their Charter
which says very clearly at the outset of
their Charter it sets forth their goal
it says Israel will exist until Islam
obliterates it later in the charter it
invokes a Hadith a saying of the Prophet
Muhammad calling for the killing of all
Jews so this is part of this pattern of
Jews looking for peace hoping for peace
willing to make tremendous compromises
for peace and rejectionists taking
control of the Palestinian side and
ensuring that there is no peace but
rather a full rejection of the Jewish
claim full rejection of Jewish rights
full rejection of a Jewish connection to
this
land which has led to so much tragedy
and is leading now to one of the
greatest spikes in murder and death
we've seen in the conflict okay well
that summed it up pretty cly um the
Palestinian side is claiming that in
1947 the offer put forth uh offered
Israelis 56% of this area is that
accurate um I I would say my
understanding was around 52% however
okay 52
56% 70% of that was Desert there was the
Jewish 50 5 52 56% was overwhelmingly
desert the netive desert the Arab 50%
was the beautiful Highlands of Judea
Samaria
Galilee it was a it was a very good
offer Jerusalem with it Jewish majority
Jerusalem has had a Jewish majority
since the mid 1800s was not given to the
Jewish state so this this this was a an
offer that could have ended the conflict
but instead of accepting the offer
splitting the land working together to
develop their respective countries and
the entire Middle East and and by the
way throughout this period there have
been Palestinians who've wanted peace
throughout this period there have been
Palestinians who wanted compromise who
wanted to work together build together
live together unfortunately none of them
lasted very long when they got to
positions of leadership because the
Palestinian national movement has been
dominated by three leaders who I
mentioned all of whom were violent
rejectionists who refused to compromise
and refus to live in peace so when I
speak about the Palestinians I want to
be clear I'm talking about their
leadership I I I personally know
Palestinians I love Palestinians who
would love they see what Israel's doing
they see what Israel's doing now with
the Gulf States to develop their
economies to create this new high-tech
startup Middle East they want to be a
part of that but they are cursed by a
leadership that refuses to embrace the
path of building a future together and
constantly dredges up complaints mostly
false about the past to justify violence
in the
present okay and then uh
for for like the current situation for
Hamas
uh the the Palestinian side is claiming
that they're Freedom Fighters right and
that their story if I can sum it up
badly is they're fighting back against
the this is Israeli power that's slowly
forcing them them into smaller and
smaller
areas that's that's what that side is is
saying and I looked at the stats about
how people in America who I don't think
are very like I'm certainly not educated
in this matter at all when it started I
had almost no background information
about what was going on it was just you
know Chaos online and you're getting
thrown different stories from both sides
um what is Gaza like for people who live
there because from what I've been told
Israel's kind of separated this area and
landlocked it and is horrible for people
there
yeah of all th those people complaining
about the map need to take some some
responsibility um Palestinians rarely
take responsibility for their mistakes
the decisions their leaders made they
could have had a state that would have
been 70% of this land in 1937 they
rejected it and rejected it violently
murdering hundreds if not thousands of
Jews Holocaust happens United Nations
gets involved decides this time we're
going to make another two-state offer
this time we're going to give the Jews
50% the Arabs 50% although like I said
the Jews 50% was 70%
desert they could have said yes instead
they said no and and and the very next
day I they launched a war of
annihilation against the Jews of
Palestine they like to complain about
the NABA the disaster of 48 they never
take responsibility for the fact that
they were the ones who rejected the
offer of estate and they launched a
violent attack against their Jewish
neighbors the very next day this was a
war Israel did not want this was a war
Israel did not seek they wanted to just
rescue the people in displaced persons
camps in Europe and bring them into a
state to build instead these people came
off the boat often wearing their y their
ALS schwitz uniforms was the only
clothes they had and then right to the
front a third of Israel's dead in that
war of Independents were Holocaust
Survivors they didn't want the war seek
the war it was imposed upon them by
Palestinian Arabs who rejected the offer
of estate so again they they want to
complain about the results of their
ression you know I look back in history
and I think you know Germany did
Terrible Things in World War II Japan
did Terrible Things in World War II but
after the fact after the United States
defeated them they never came back and
blamed the United States for their
suffering they at least had the decency
to say this was the outcome of a war we
chose and we started but the Palestines
will never admit to having made these
terrible tragic violent Arabs and
instead like to blame the Israelis for
the suffering that came from the wars
they chose and could have been avoided
you know just just as an as sign during
this period when Jews were returning to
Israel under the British mandate the
great the highest years of Jewish
immigration were from
1914 to
1930 uh
37 um the highest years of Jewish
immigration when the Brit British were
letting Jews in Jews were coming in by
the hundreds of thousands you know what
happened to the Arab population of
Palestine during this period did Jews
have to kick them out to take their
homes did Jews have to kick them out to
take their fields to the Arab population
plummet it grew
dramatically it grew it was a population
explosion but the population only
exploded in those areas to which Jews
were returning so if you look during
this period the population of Jaffa to
which Jews were returning grew by
something like
120% the Jewish population of H to which
Jews were returning grew by something
like
130% the the Arab population of these
places the Arab population of cities to
which Jews were not returned like
Bethlehem or nablas grew by like 30%
natural increase what was happening was
the Jews were creating economic
opportunities and Arabs were immigrating
into Palestine and IM migrating from the
Arab areas to the Jewish areas so it was
the beginning what could have been a
wonderful partnership a wonderful
partnership where Jews brought Economic
Opportunity Arabs dreamed in and
together they built a modern beautiful
state it was a choice to reject this it
was a choice to instead launch a war of
annihilation and the people who made
that choice need to step up and bear
some of the
responsibility by the way in none of
this am I saying the Israelis are
perfect the Israelis never made
mistakes what I'm saying though is there
is a clear pattern over the history of
offer after offer Jews saying yes Arabs
saying no quite often violently
so to get back to your asking about
Gaza uh Israel was attacked in 1948 the
Arabs rejected a state and attacked
Israel the um the Palestinian Arabs
started the war but then the neighboring
Arab Arab countries joined in that war
to destroy Israel and they announced the
war of annihilation will throw the Jews
into the sea Egypt conquered some land
um uh in the British what was the
British mandate for Palestine that was
that that wasn't Egypt and that's called
Gaza they conquered this strip along the
coast next to Egypt Jordan conquered
land uh called the West Bank Judean
Samar they didn't create a Palestinian
state in this land they conquered it
they annexed it Egypt stayed in Gaza and
uh Jordan stayed in the West Bank when
they attacked Israel again in 1967 in an
effort to destroy Israel again in
1967 Israel once again defended itself
and in this war of self-defense Israel
took Gaza and Israel took the west bank
and then there's question emerged of
what do we do with these
territories in
1967 the Palestinians for the first time
a majority of them started to feel that
they weren't just members of the larger
Arab nation that spans from IO to Iraq
they started to feel that they were a
separate people and they started to call
themselves Palestinians so after Israel
liberated this land from Jordan and
Egypt in 1967 and were trying to debate
what to do with it the Israeli cabinet
actually split half the Israeli cabinet
said we should give the West Bank back
to Jordan in exchange for peace but
another half said no no let's not give
it to Jordan let's give it to the Arabs
who actually lived there who are
starting to call themselves palestin
inian and they actually found
Palestinians living in the land who said
sure we would like to be independent
we'll take your offer of
Independence and that's when the Arab
League met in cartoon Sudan and issued
its Infamous trinos no peace with Israel
no negotiation with Israel no
recognition of Israel the same
Palestinian interlocutors got back to
Israel and said the Arab League has
spoken we can't talk to you we'll be
killed so Israel stayed in control of
this land and isra stayed in control of
this land until another Peace effort was
made in 2000 where they brought the
Palestinian Authority in and gave them
autonomy in the West Bank and autonomy
in Gaza and the Palestinian Authority
ruled in Gaza until M staged the bloody
coup and Hamas took it over and so
that's more or less the story of Gaz and
how we have situation today we have
these two pieces of land that were
proposed as a Palestinian state that
could have been a Palestinian state but
it was rejected by the Palestinians
repeatedly so now the Palestinian
Authority rules the West Bank with
autonomy and Hamas rules Gaza completely
they could have turned it into a
Singapore of the Middle East Israel was
ready to work with them build with them
construct with them they chose instead
to turn it into a large Terror base
their choice like every other bad choice
the Palestinian leadership has
made what a mess so so uh I've heard
online that the reason that they
Israel's bombing civilian areas like
hospitals Etc is because Hamas is
actually hiding weapons in these areas
is that is that true
yeah Hamas has a
strategy Hamas doesn't think it can
defeat Israel
militarily he wants to defeat Israel in
in the court of international opinion so
it has a very clear strategy to attack
Israel and provoke a
response but then Hamas chooses to
operate out of fire missiles out of hide
arms within civilian areas it's a double
War Crum when they attack Israeli
civilians with their missiles or when
they Massacre over a thousand like they
just did clear War crime but then when
they hide in civilian areas and operate
out of Civilian areas it's another War
crime so Israel three choices when Hamas
attacks them like this it has to do what
every other country on Earth would do in
attack like this it has to defend its
citizens so it has three
choices one one extreme it could say oh
no Hamas is smart they're operating out
of Civilian areas if we go in and try to
pinpoint and take out Hamas we may harm
civilians and we don't want to harm
civilians therefore well played Hamas
fire as many rockets at us as you want
murder as many of our civilians as you
want our hands are tied because we don't
want to harm civilians that's one option
it's an unacceptable option no country
on the face of the Earth will let a
terrorist organization murder its
civilians and not fight back that's
option one option three let's go to The
Other Extreme Chia Russia Israel has the
ability to wipe out every single
building and every single human being in
Gaza just destroy it pound it into the
Stone Age teach them a lesson that's
what Russia did in grne to stop the chin
Rebellion unacceptable if you care about
international law and human rights you
are not allowed to Target civilians
that's what separates the Hamas
terrorists who intentionally gy Target
civilians from a moral Army that targets
the terrorists you're not allowed to
Target civilians you're not allowed to
indiscriminately bomb and Israel refuses
to do that so it leaves Israel with the
middle option Choice number two and this
is how Israel behaved in every one of
its Wars up till today and this is how
Israel will behave in this war and that
is they will do everything possible to
go after the terrorists of Hamas while
protecting the innocent Palestinian
civilians of Gaza this means giving
warnings like they've been doing to flee
areas into which the Israeli Army will
enter this means when they want to bomb
a specific building calling everyone in
that building and saying please leave
we're coming this means if you know that
some people have not left the building
they do what's called roof knocking they
drop a bomb on the roof that makes a
very loud scary sound but doesn't kill
anyone to let everyone know we're
serious we're coming and then when they
see that all the civilians have left
they will they will destroy the building
they will do everything and by the way
in doing this they give up the element
of surprise in doing this in protecting
Palestinian civilians Israel puts its
own civilians at risk because what
happens when you drop leaflet saying
we're coming what happens when you call
a building saying we're coming what
happens when you drop that knock on the
roof
the civilians know to flee but so too do
the terrorists and they do flee and they
do take missiles with them and they live
to fight another day and that means more
missiles will be fired on Israel more
attacks will be made against Israel
every time Israel does this it knows
it's putting it's taking a risk on its
own civilians but it does this because
it doesn't want to harm innocent
Palestinian civilians it goes through
enormous lengths to avoid Palestinian
civilian deaths but it can't go so far
as to say we're not going to fight Hamas
so if Hamas attacks us and it attacks us
from civilian areas and fires from
civilian areas we'll do our best but if
there are civilian deaths that is on
Hamas and its double War crime of
attacking Israeli civilians from
palestin and civilian areas want to
quote a friend of mine Richard Kent he's
uh he was the British
commander of British forces in
Afghanistan who witnessed a lot of this
studied it and he said in history of
warfare there has never been an army as
moral as Israel's Army that goes to
Greater lengths than Israel's Army to
protect innocent civilians on the other
side um it's it's it's it's really um
quite amazing what Israel does and has
done to avoid withan deaths but they
happen they will happen I'm I'm I'm
afraid in this conflict and everyone
will be click to quick to blame Israel
and ignore the provocation the
intentional
Slaughter rape decapitation of of of
over over 1000 00 Israelis by Hamas and
they'll be quick to overlook the fact
that Hamas is
now operating from civilian areas hiding
in civilian areas and when Israel warned
civilians to leave North Gaza Hamas is
telling them not to leave Hamas does not
want them to leave Hamas wants them to
be In Harm's Way because they know when
civilians are killed they'll be
able with no shame to claim this is
Israel Israel's fault and two-thirds of
the world will believe them and never
bother look into who started this and
who's causing this none of this would
have happened if Hamas didn't wake up a
week ago and say hey let's go into
Israel and start
slaughtering kids at a music festival
going door-to-door in communities and
shooting women children their
husbands they chose this war Israel has
no option but to respond they'll be
careful they'll be as careful as
possible but there will be civilian
deaths and that's on the
Mons okay okay so just one followup for
that area so uh what I've read is that
and like I
said I don't trust anything I read
online just generally speaking because
everybody has an opinion and they're all
different so it's so hard to to
understand what's going on especially if
you don't have a historical firsthand
perspective um when when Israel gives
out warnings to say hey we're going
after this one building or this is where
we're going to go what I've read uh two
things one that Hamas will say no stay
there um and two that the people in
there actually have no place to go to
because there's a lack of bomb shelters
Etc in that area
so what do you think about that let's be
clear Hamas is filled with bomb shelters
filled with a network of safe tunnels
underground unfortunately uses that for
itself doesn't give its civilians access
to that there are Israel has always made
safe corridors like like now safe
Corridor here are the hours when you can
leave on the safe Corridor and here are
times when you can go Hamas is small
Hamas is narrow but there's still plenty
of places to go if your build building
is being
targeted it's a tragedy right if if I
were a Palestinian living in a building
and Hamas moved into my building and
started firing missiles from from my
building and started hiding missiles in
my building or using it as a command
center I'd be very
upset um I feel for people innocent
people caught in this
situation but it it doesn't mean that
it's Israel's
fault it's hamas's fault that it chose
to operate from a civilian building and
did so because it wants the Palestinian
deaths because it knows it will earn the
sympathy of the world with the
Palestinian deaths because it knows the
world is never going to bother to look
at who started it and we'll never bother
to look at how well Israel conducts its
counterterrorism operations compared to
Britain and the United States let alone
compared to a monster like Russia and so
um it creates these tragedies it wants
these
tragedies yeah that makes sense and and
if someone doesn't believe that well
what else did amas hope to accomplish
when it sent over 1500 troops amas
terrorists across the border with
explicit instructions to slaughter
Israeli civilians what else did they
want to accomplish other than to force
Israel to
respond was was there some other
military objective there there was no
valid military objection by the way I
should
add Israel abides by international law
of War Hamas doesn't you're not allowed
to Target civilians that that's all they
do is Target
civilians but when you defend yourself
you are allowed to Target military
targets legitimate military targets even
if there will be civilian casualties
everyone talks about proportionality is
oh Israel's response has to be
proportional the only time the
international law of War speaks of
proportionality is to say that in any
operation you conduct the number of
civilians killed has to be proportional
to not an excess of your legitimate
military expectation of that operation
that's what it says these are the
international rules of law if Israel
ever targeted a civilian with the goal
of killing a civilian it would be in
violation of international law it would
be a terrorist like Hamas and people
like me would never defend
it but Israel doesn't do that Israel
only targets military targets legitimate
military targets and in the process
there are sometimes civilian casualties
the international laws of war allow for
that recognize that permit that
otherwise you'd never be able to defend
yourself from a terrorist entity like
Kamal okay I mean all that's pretty
clear uh one of the questions I had on
here is were Israel's security measures
such as the West Bank barrier and its
blockade on Gaza Justified because part
of what I'm hearing in the news is so
there's been this blockade on Gaza and
it's in order to protect Israeli
citizens from Hamas but it's isolating
all the people in Gaza and creating this
you know 2 million person resentment
pile that's just building up and I mean
has exploded
recently was there was this like that
was the only thing that was the only
option basically yeah they they love to
confuse cause and effect right
so Israel's blockade of Gaza was not the
cause of Hamas terrorism it was the
effect of Hamas terrorism there was no
blockade until Hamas took over Gaza and
started using Gaza to attack Israel and
fire missiles into Israel and at that
point Israel did what it is allowed to
do under international law what any
other country on God's green earth would
do he said you know we're not so sure we
want to let you get material to build
more of these weapons and bombs and they
put a blockade around it people
criticize Israel's security fence around
the West Bank they say this is what
causes unhappiness in the West Bank it
wasn't the cause of terrorism and
unhappiness it was a response to
terrorism the border between Israel and
the bank was more open than the border
between the United States and Canada I
used to spend a lot of time on an
Israeli M right on the border you'd walk
you wouldn't even know you were now in
in in an Arab Village abla right right
across uh in the West Bank there was no
border and Palestinians came in by the
hundreds of thousands to work in Israel
Israelis went into the Palestinian
territories to shop to eat at
restaurants to go to the dentists which
were less expensive in the West Bank
they used to go to Gaza too for dead
less expensive there was no fence until
Arafat rejected aood barack's offer of a
Palestinian state in the West Bank did
so violently with the second in tiata
suicide bombers came in and blew up over
a thousand Israelis and then finally
belatedly Israel said Gee we might need
to do something to stop these suicide
bombers from coming in and blowing up
our civilians then they built the fence
so it it's stupendous the gal of trying
to cry victim and trying to claim that
what Israel was forced to do by your
terrorism is the cause of your terrorism
again the tragedy here Mela is that none
of this had to be there could have been
a very different Middle East and what we
see emerging now between through the
Abraham Accords with Israel and the Gulf
States and the investment and and and
the cooperation that could have been
from day one W back in the day when
hundreds of thousands of Arabs were
streaming into Palestine to be closer to
Jewish cities with Jewish economic
opportunities it was a
win-win Jewish Jewish
businesses Arab labor Arab Enterprise
Jewish investors it all could have
created this wonderful new country but
instead Palestinians got leaders
determined to reject the Jewish presence
reject peace with the Jews reject
partnersh ship with the Jews and insist
instead on Wars of annihilation and
created this new reality and to this
very day Gaza used to have an open
border with Israel too there hundreds of
thousands of gazin used to work in
Israel and there were better wages in
Israel than Gaza Israelis used to go
into Gaza all the time and it only
stopped tragically not because Israel
wanted a wall not because Israel wanted
a barrier but because Hamas Terror
forced Israel's hand and by the way
something else I'll add when I speak
about Palestinian Terror I I don't call
the the victims Jews Like many people do
yeah 95% are Jews but they're Israelis
you know during the second inata when
Arafat rejected barack's offer for
Palestinian State one of the restaurants
they blew up was a restaurant in hia hia
is a mixed Arab Jewish City it was one
of these cities that flourished with
Arab
immigration uh until Palestinian leaders
rejected uh the Jewish state and
attacked it in
1947 so there's still a MX City still a
lot of Arabs and Jews and there's a
restaurant there known the fact that
it's a mixed restaurant Jews and Arabs
like to get together and eat humus and
fap there Palestinian terrorists blew
that restaurant up during the second
inata and they targeted it on purpose
because it represents everything they're
against it represents tolerance
coexistence and a future together one of
the people killed um by Hamas rocket
fire at Jerusalem two days ago it fell
short and it hit the city of Abu go Abu
go always had wonderful relationships uh
with Jewish leaders it stayed there it's
a big thriving an Arab sitting next to
Jerusalem Arab resen of Abu Goos with
his whole life ahead of him was just
killed by by Palestinian rocket fired
one of the people they slaughtered the
other day um was an Arab ambulance
worker who went with his colleagues in
the ambulance Squad to take care of of
of of of all the injured at the music
festival they slaughtered him too so the
people killed are not just Jews I I
think I think it would be a lot easier
for the world if these were just Jews
sorry world they're not just Jews
they're also Arab Muslims and Arab
Christians all people who have decided
on a different path than Hamas people
who want to live together work together
Thrive together Build Together Hamas has
chosen a different way why do we give
them a veto why do we give them our
sympathy why do we let their disgusting
tactics work why do we let them shift
the blame to Israel the ones who have
rejected peace they're the ones who
rejected statehood they're the ones who
rejected coexistence they should bear
the blame but the world is so quick to
listen to their cries and and and and
and and by by the nonsense that the only
reason they're targeting Israel is
because Israel took some action I will
remind you what the Hamas Charter
says the Hamas Charter their founding
document says Israel will exist until
Islam will obliterate it they don't want
a two-state solution they want to
destroy Israel
and it cites theth the saying of the
Prophet Muhammad calling for Muslims to
kill all
Jews it has nothing to do with the
blockade Israel imposed after Hamas
started its Terror campaign the terror
campaign was the point behind Hamas in
the first
place and you know and it's not just
Jews who suffer it is peaceloving Arabs
who suffer on both sides of
them so does this all kind of chalk up
to just just a religious war and it's
just manifested in this way now like is
it a fundamental disagreement between
certain not all Muslims but certain
Muslims well yeah I I I I I think that's
fair to say the Palestinian national
movement started as a secular movement
it was a secular nationalist movement
under yaser
araa that embrac terrorism as a tactic
so rejectionism we reject that that Jews
have any right to be in there ancestral
Homeland Jews Jews among all people on
Earth do not have the right to
self-determination and and our tactic in
in rejecting Jewish self-determination
will be terrorism and they and they they
Pioneer terrorism the the intentional
targeting and murder of innocent
civilians and and that was their goal
they and that's how they proceeded until
they found Rivals from Islamic movements
and that main rival is hamam and
supposes this from a more Islamic
perspective an extreme Islamic
perspective a lot of my Muslim friends
are very adamant don't you dare let them
take my Islam don't you dare let them
discredit my Islam my Islam is is not a
religion that that celebrates
decapitating babies and raping women
don't let them steal my
Islam but this is what they do in the
name of Islam Hamas and so today I would
argue the the the dominance strain of
rejectionism the dominant strain of
Terror within the Palestinian Camp is
from this religious perspective again
it's an abuse of Islam much like uh Isis
was was an abuse of Islam much like the
mulas in Iran are abuse of Islam this is
not the interpretation of Islam that
many Muslims have uh but unfortunately
there are many who share it many who
embrace it many who will kill for it and
many will happily die for
it I think we should touch briefly on
the Abraham Accords because you
mentioned them earlier and I think
they're important uh and I think a lot
of Americans don't even know that they
exist or that they were going to exist
do you uh could you describe what they
are what their goal was and whether or
not that's even a possibility now yeah
um so you know like I was saying before
when when the Jews you know they find
their waves of return throughout history
Jew Jews never you know the Roman rans
exiled the Jews in 70 AD but but it
wasn't a very successful Exile there
were always Jews living there they were
probably the the majority until 500 the
plurality until 1000 and whenever local
rulers um would let would let Jews come
back they streamed back so when Jew
started streaming back in this latest
wave um they reached out to the King of
Jordan King Abdullah the grandfather of
the current King and they spoke about
hey you know we Jews want to build our
homeland and our ancestral home um we're
Jewish nationalist who want to build a
home here you're an Arab nationalist you
want to build an Arab Homeland in your
country don't you think we should do
this together don't you think together
we can build
something even better and King Abdullah
at first embraced that and there was
lots of talk about together building
this new Middle East and
then there was a violent rejection of
that by Palestinian leaders and King
Abdullah turned his back on that and
this idea of Jews and Arabs joining
hands to build a new Middle East was was
put on ice it was always the dream of
the early zionists was put on Ice um
through war after war after war of
annihilation until the Abraham Accords
and the Abraham Accords was sort of the
taking out of the freezer this original
Dream It's A Beautiful dream where Arabs
and Jews look at each other and say
we're both the children of Abraham you
know we're cousins really Arabic and
Hebrew are similar Semitic languages
Jews and Arabs are similar Semitic
people here we are Jews back in the
Middle East to which were indigenous
Arabs having achieved Independence in
the Middle East let's do this together
let's build this together let's be the
brothers we were meant to be let's be
the Kindred Spirits we were meant to be
so the Abraham of course was this
beautiful realization of this ancient
Zionist dream and it was going so well
with the United Arab Emirates with
Bahrain with
Morocco all of a sudden they were they
were getting together trying to solve
the Region's problems can we solve the
problem of too little water in the
region can we solve the problem of too
too few jobs and parts of the region can
we build companies together
infrastructure
together and it was going so well and it
was pointing the way towards the new
Middle East but there's a problem with
that new Middle East there are those in
the region who don't want to see peace
who don't want to see cooperation who
don't want to see coexistence and they
are led by ARA haven't mentioned Iran up
till now but you know we need to
understand Hamas is an Iran client esbah
is an Iran clent they are funded by Iran
trained by Iran and directed by Iran
Iran is afraid of Peace in the region it
wants to destroy Israel and it wants to
destroy Saudi Arabia and it wants to
destroy the Emirates so when it saw this
block forming this peace block with the
potential for all this Economic
Development and everything that came
with it it decided it needed to stop it
and it had a and if you ask me why did
they decide to slaughter over a thousand
Israelis last week it was to to stop
this peace process once
again and I'm so sad to say that it
seems to have had that intended effect
before two weeks ago Saudi peace with
Saudi Arabia was only a matter of of
weeks if you know months if not weeks it
was going to happen and transform the
region Saudi Arabia announced yesterday
it's putting the peace on hold they knew
what they were doing they knew if they
could provoke Israel to respond if they
could show Palestinian dead it would
intimidate Saudi Arabia into banding
peace and it might even show the Abraham
Accord so once again in our day the same
extremist that stopped peace in 37 that
stopped peace in 47 that stopped peace
in 67 that stopped peace in 2000 that
stopped peace in 2008 have once again
stopped
peace in
2023 and and they do it through the same
means each and every time by targeting
civilians by slaughtering civilians by
murdering civilians it's very sadad to
seat because a lot of us saw a little
light at the end of the tunnel of the
Abraham
cours one thing I want to note too this
investment didn't just go outside uh
there's an entrepreneur um who started
investing a lot of money in building
startups um with Palestinian Partners in
rala and the goal is to turn rala into
which is the capital of the Palestinian
Authority moest Bank into a little Tel
AV and this Israeli entrepreneur was
investing a lot of time an effort to
help Palestinian entrepreneurs do this
so maybe finally the Palestinians would
give up these old grievances that are
most made up anyway and clinging to the
past and start looking towards the
future and built
it uh his daughter was just murdered at
that Music Festival this entrepreneur oh
man Visions Clash so Michaela I people
are going to you're going to hear a lot
of people saying well there's two sides
here um you know Israel Israel blockaded
Gaza um Israel um kill civilians um true
Israel blockaded Gaza but again why did
it do it why it wouldn't have done it if
Hamas wouldn't have used Gaza to to hit
Israel with Terror Israel does kill
civilians
why because Israel's provoked to
defending Itself by by by Hamas rocket
fire or by Hamas Slaughters and though
it is better than any other Army on the
face of the Earth at targeting the
guilty and bearing the innocent it
cannot do it perfectly when Hamas hides
among the innocent so these things are
true but the context is key and I will
tell you this I am confident that anyone
who comes with a complaint about Israel
if you peel back if you look behind it
you'll find that the driving force
behind all of this is the tragic
leadership of the Palestinians who are
bent on stopping peace any way possible
including primarily Slaughter of
civilians called
terrorism do you think the the Abraham
Accords so that was something that was
done under the Trump Administration so
years ago right that this was kind of
organized is there a reason that it
wasn't
finalized like sooner seems a little
urgent well I think I think for years
um Arabs were hostage just like the
Arabs of Palestine thousand L Bank are
Hostage to this Palestinian leadership
that's really not interested in peace
and compromise the Arab world was
Hostage to them too they were afraid to
make peace with Israel when they could
be accused of having betrayed or abandon
the Palestinian cause but after time
after after the Palestinians kept
rejecting offers after the Palestinians
kept resorting to Terror to
intentionally slaughtering
Innocents Palestinian civilians many of
them got tired of their leadership and
many leaders of the Arab world got tired
and said we're no longer going to be
held hostage to this Palestinian
leadership that has no interest in peace
and well interest in coexistence and so
finally it took a push but finally they
said yeah we are willing to make peace
with Israel we are willing to join hands
with Israel because it's ultimately
governments are responsible to their own
people and their safety and their
prosperity and the United Arab Emirates
and Bahrain and Morocco and Sudan all
said you know what this development will
help create Economic Opportunity for our
citizens and this Alliance will create
defense for our citizens and then the
final piece of course is Iran Iran looms
out there as a as a as a power bent on
the destruction of Israel and the
dominance Shiite dominance of sun
kingdoms like Saudi Arabia and like the
United Arab Emirates and finally it was
that fear of Iran that helped them
overcome any fear of being accused of
abandoning the Palestinians to say no
we're going to act now to defend our
people and ensure the prosperity of our
people and we're going to move forward
um Iran is pulling the strings behind
all this which once again those who who
get too CAU up in the idea that somehow
this is a response to some Israeli
grievance they're missing the big
picture the only grievance uh Iran has
with Israel is its very existence and
they don't mince words they say it
constantly we will wipe Israel off the
map we will destroy Israel we will
obliterate Israel and they need
it and so they're the ones who armed
Hamas Hamas and gave Hamas this order if
War breaks out with hisb in the north it
won't be because of Any grievance on the
border with Lebanon Israel took out
every last civilian
Soldier and any presence in Gaza back in
2005 Israel withdrew every last TR from
Lebanon before that this is not anything
to do with any madeup grievance this is
a direct order from Iran as an
overriding geost geostrategic goal of
dominating the region and destroying
Israel okay like I say I have a lot of
dear Palestinian friends uh who suffer
under Hamas and who suffer under the PA
and would like to have different
Palestinian leadership it makes their
blood boil when these people don't sit
in gazel and suffer um sit outside in
some Western academic institution and
rationalize the leadership that has
ruined their lives nothing makes them
angrier than some apologist getting on
the show and saying oh you have to
understand this is Israel's fault um so
these people are out there but we all
need to think critically everyone needs
to think critically about everything
I've said everyone needs to think
critically about everything people from
the other side say but the the guarantee
I make to people is if you study this
history if you take the time and learn
this history you will see this pattern
emerge and you'll find that every excuse
every rationalization given for the
murder of in inocence melts away under
under further
screwing there is no rationalization for
intentionally slaughtering civilians to
begin
with there is no rational of
justification but even if you want to
claim one that melts away last thing too
Israel's blockade the Gaza that it it
installed only after
terrorism everyone forgets Gaza Gaza has
a very long border with Egypt Egypt
closed that border too I wonder why they
were exporting Terror to Egypt as well
but no one seems to blame Egypt for
closing the border and trying to stop
terrorism only Israel gets blamed when
it dares to defend itself when it dares
to survive and this double standard also
gets a little tired no one ever defends
other people and then defend them
criticizes other people and then defend
themselves from terrorism it's natural
it's accepted when Russia obliterated
half a grne Chia which was a war crime
which did Target civilians which Israel
would never do where where were the
complaints on college campuses in
America China today is perpetrating a
real genocide against the Muslim Wagers
in in in its West a real genocide
putting them into camps we don't hear
anyone complaining but only when Israel
dares to defend itself and said we will
not be slaughtered like sheep we will do
what any other people on God's green
earth would do is there this outrage
that's why so much of this outrage to me
is false doesn't ring true doesn't ring
sincere um why do you think this has
permeated the college campus so
effectively like I I saw in in New York
Times Square and in Toronto where I'm
from there are pro Palestinian protests
yeah like downtown why is it working why
is the propaganda if if it's propaganda
working so well here well I think again
at the very superficial level this plugs
very well into a woke mindset was on
college campuses today if you're a
victim you're innocent um if you're not
a victim you're guilty um people of
color are are are considered to be you
know innocent victims if if you're if
you're considered white not so and
Indigenous people are of course uh
evaluating if you're from outside of a
region come to that region on L so so
there is a popular anti Israel narrative
that has come to dominate woke circles
in these spaces on college campuses none
of it's true so I'm going to say the
narrative now none of it's true but the
narrative is that a group of Jews in
Europe with no connection to the land of
Israel Jews have no connection to the
land of Israel said hey that's some nice
land there let's go take it and they
went to a nation called Palestine and
they expelled all the Arabs that were
living there in Palestine and took it
over for themselves and so you have have
the oppression of indigenous people
people of color by white
Europeans and since they're suffering uh
they they causes just and and and and
the Israelis are the oppressors so their
causes unjust now that's wrong on every
level of course the European Jews who
came back to their ancestral Homeland to
which they are
indigenous came came to land in which
they have the deepest of connections
they were never considered white in
Europe they were considered another race
that's why they were slaughtered by the
Nazis because they weren't White they
were another race they were submitted
for centuries Jews living in Europe were
told go back to Israel go back to
Palestine so they
did but the majority of Israelis don't
come from Europe they are refugees from
the Muslim Middle East because after
Israel dared to survive the war of
annihilation in 1947 and
1948 every Arab country kicked out its
Jews Jews used to be between a third and
a half of Baghdad all expelled my
father-in-law who I'm here with right
now was SP from Tripoli Libya
Palestinians complain about what
happened to them after the war they
started in
1948 my my father-in-law's family was
extraordinarily wealthy in Libya trip
when they were kicked out they ended up
Living 10 brothers and sisters and two
parents in a one room apartment they
they lived in utter poverty there are
complaints on both sides the difference
is Israel doesn't live in the past and
nurse these Grievances and dream of
Revenge one day from day one the
Israelis had tried to build a future and
get and get over the past and the
Palestinians have gone in a different
direction so this is a myth that Jews
are from Europe and have no connection
to the land it's a myth that they came
in and kicked anyone out like I said the
Palestinian the the Arab population of
this land did not decrease when Jews
came back it exploded when Jews came
back and then the whole Refugee crisis
was not because Israel started a war to
kick them out it's because the Arabs
lost the war of annihilation that they
started to drive the Jews out but not
knowing all of this this fits very well
into the Western imagination the victim
mentality they see the Palestinians
victims of a settler
Colonial genocidal Israeli regime and
they do what I would do if that
narrative were true if this narrative
were true I'd be protesting Israel too
it's just not true it's the opposite of
the truth and by the way I know one of
the things I do in my day job is is I
run a group called The makabe Tas for
and we bring College leaders uh to
Israel and we try to bring people who
dominate campus politics which means
these days on most American campuses
these are people of the left and they
all they're Israel skeptical if not
outright Israel critical and the amaz
and we bring them to Israel and the
Palestinian Authority by the way we want
them to see both
sides the amazing thing is how this trip
changes them and transform them because
what they see is that the reality of
isra Isel is starkly at odds with the
anti-israel narrative they were fed and
so this trip changes them um and again a
lot of them don't don't come back waving
the Israelite FL but almost all of them
will say you know what this is a lot
more complex than I was led to believe
and the answer is not to single out and
scapegoat Israel as I was told to do the
answer lies elsewhere and the answer
lies where it always
lies in trying to talk to one another
trying understand one another
recognizing the humanity of one another
and in daring to dream of a region where
Jews and Arabs are not enemies but these
cousins these Semitic peoples join hands
and build a Middle East that's more
Dynamic and prosperous than any other
region in the globe it was the dream
since day one the Zionist dream it was a
dream we just tasted during the Abraham
Accords but at every turn including
today extremists violent extremists have
killed the dream and my only hope for
the future is that the dream will live
that this two shall pass that Israel
will defend itself will dismantle Hamas
and that one day the Palestinians may
get leaders who don't want to murder and
Destroy Israel but actually want to
build
Palestine that's the day there'll be
peace that's the day there'll be
Prosperity that's the day when the
Zionist Vision will come to pass and the
region will become what it always should
have
been okay well thank you for joining me
that was very
informative much appreciated thanks for
having me I appreciate the
opportunity Norman finl welcome to my
podcast thank you for having me
on uh so I wanted to bring you on to get
um a different perspective of what's
going on in the Middle East
I'm not educated in this area at all uh
so I have a list of questions to ask you
but let let's get started I think I
think we should start with just a brief
background of the history of the Israeli
and Palestine conflict and what led to
today obviously when you try to give a
background story of a conflict the
question is always where do you begin
because depending on where you begin it
can be seen as a partisan
issue um I will take where we begin at
1948 the indigenous population of
Palestine
numbered um about
1,300,000
the what were called back then the
Zionist settlers namely Jews who came to
Palestine roughly from the beginning of
the 20th century
on they numbered roughly
600,000 by
1947 there was a
irreconcilable
conflict between the indigenous Arab
population and the Zionist Jewish
settlers that conflict was then thrown
into the hands of the newly created
United
Nations and the UN was its designated
responsibility
was to try to work out a resolution a
settlement of the conflict not
necessarily applying the highest
principles of justice but trying to
combine as in most conflicts principles
of Justice with practicality what's
possible the United Nations General
Assembly in what's called UN resolution
181 it divided Palestine or proposed
that Palestine be divided into two
states an Arab state which would
compromise approxim
comprise approximately 44% of
Palestine and a Jewish state which would
comprise approximately
56% of
Palestine on the Arab side did not
accept that
recommendation for two main reasons one
they were the indigenous
population and number two that and
therefore their rights should have
priority uh or their desires and
aspirations should have
priority and number two because the
division did not remotely correlate with
the demographic balance in Palestine
the 600,000 Jews were allocated
56% the Palestinian Arabs were allocated
44% a conflict then ensued What's called
the first Arab Israeli War in which
neighboring Arab states also
intervened by the end of the
war uh Israel had absorbed not the
56% that was allocated it in the
partition resolution
181 but they absorbed
80% of
Palestine two areas were not absorbed by
Israel number one the Gaza Strip which
came under Egyptian administrative
control and the West what came to be
called the West Bank including East East
Jerusalem which came under Jordanian
control in the course of Israel's
Creation in
1948 it expelled about
90% of the
population within the Border 90% of the
indigenous population within the borders
that became
Israel of those 90% roughly
750,000 p Indians were expelled from the
area that became
Israel of those
750,000 about 250 to 290,000 they fled
to
Gaza and they are the
origins of the Gaza population today the
population of Gaz at the time was about
880,000 so now that that population of
Gaza was swamped by the refugees who
were expelled in
1948 without wanting to anticipate too
much of what's going to come in a few
moments so those
refugees and their
descendants now constitute now meaning
today they constitute approximately 7 %
of the population of
Gaza so when we hear today about the
population of Gaza roughly now 2.2
million people of those 2.2 million
people approximately
70% constitute refugees and their
descendants now to go back to where we
were in the very uh condensed historical
record in
1967 there was another war between
Israel and the neighboring Arab states
and the course of that
war two things happened it was the
second if you want if the term can be
used it was the Second Great
exposion about
300,000
Palestinians were expelled
from the areas that Israel now count
conquered and the areas Israel now
conquered were the Gaza Strip and the
West Bank including East
Jerusalem so the bottom line is in
1900 Palestine was the population was
about
90%
Palestinian
Arab in
1947 the population was
about
1,300,000
Palestinian Arabs and
600,000
Jews and in
1947 before the popular partition plan
Israelis owned about 6% of the land in
Palestine the partition resolution
awarded the newly created state of
Israel 56% of Palestine by the end of
the war of
1948 Israel controlled 80% of
Palestine after the June
1967 war Israel now
controlled all of
Palestine the whole of Palestine had now
come under Israeli control
under international
law uh because these territories were
conquered by Israel in the course of the
war under international law they weren't
part of Israel as a legal fact they
constituted what under international law
is called
occupied
territories and the abbreviation that
eventually came to be used was
opt occupied Palestinian
territories in addition to the West Bank
in Gaza in the course of the 1967 war
Israel also occupied the Syrian Golan
Heights and the Egyptian
Sinai once again the question of how to
resolve this seemingly intractable
problem was thrown into the court of the
United Nations and there were very uh
protracted
deliberations both in the general
assembly and subsequently in the
security
Council and the proposal put forth by
the security Council it was embodied and
probably the most famous resolution in
the United Nations history
it's called UN resolution
242 and the essence of UN resolution
242 is very simple it's based on
un principles international law
principles and the principles of the UN
Charter those principles are number one
which is spelled out in the Preamble to
UN resolution
242 first principle is it's inadmissible
to conquer territory by War it's
inadmissible to con conquer territory by
War
Israel acquired the West Bank Gaza
Egyptian Sinai Assyrian G Heights in the
course of a war and therefore according
to international law and un principles
Israel have no title to those
territories that was the first prong of
UN resolution
242 the second prong was
that Israel as a
state had the right under the UN Charter
to live at peace with its
neighbors and therefore the Arab states
the neighboring Arab states and any
other part parties to the conflict had a
legal obligation to accept Israel as a
state in the
region that came to be called the land
for peace land for peace solution to the
conflict namely Israel had to relinquish
control of the West Bank in Gaza now
talking strictly about the Palestinian
Israeli Dimension because there's of
course still the Egyptian Dimension with
the Sinai desert the Syrian Dimension
with the Golan Heights but from here on
in I'm going to put them to the site
because obviously we're talking about
this topic now in light of the most
recent
events so right at this point I'm going
to hone in
just on that Palestine Israel dimension
of the conflict having said that the
terms of UN resolution
242 were very
straightforward number
one Israel had to
withdraw from all the Palestinian
territories it acquired during the 1967
war what I referred to isra a moment ago
as the occupied Palestinian territories
the
opot and in
turn the Palestinians were obliged to
recognize Israel as a legal State a
member of the United Nations and as a
member of the United Nations here I'm
referring to the state of Israel it had
all the rights and
responsibilities all the rights and all
the duties of any other member
State and that was and strange as it may
sound to you it's already more than 50
years later a half century it's more
than a half century later those have
remained the terms for settling the
conflict and now the question
becomes which side has been the
obstacle to that settlement of the
conflict it could be one side it could
be the other side and of course it could
be both
sides on the Palestinian side the
leadership that emerged to represent the
Palestinians soon after the June 1967
war a leadership was called the
Palestine Liberation
Organization or the PLO and that was led
by a fellow who may be familiar to your
listeners namely yaser
Arafat beginning in the mid
1970s so once again we're talking about
a half century ago beginning in the mid
1970s the Palestinians
accepted the terms of UN resolution
242 those terms I spelled out to you a
moment
ago B withdrawal in exchange for full
recognition the Palestinians accepted
those
terms Israel did
not Israel was not prepared to
relinquish control over the territories
or at any rate parts of the territories
that they had conquered in the 1967 war
their attitude after
1967 was the same as their attitude
after
1948 you recall I said the uh UN
resolution 181 allocated 56% of
Palestine to the
Israelis they conquered
80% and by holding f pass to that
80% the International Community
eventually
aced accepted the Israeli fed are
complete so the expectation of the
Israelis after
1967 was If We Hold Fast we can retain
control over the whole of what they call
the Israel called the land of Israel
namely the West Bank Goa and so
forth so Israel was
determined not to relinquish
control over a large part of the
territory let
alone recognize a Palestinian State
living side by side with it come 19
82 what one very good Israeli political
scientist avner
Yan coming by 1982 Israel faced a very
big
problem and a Yan called it the
Palestinian peace
offensive namely the PLO was
determined with the support of the
International
Community to
gain
recognition support and eventually the
application of pressure to force Israel
to accept the terms of international law
and the UN
Charter Israel faced with the escalating
pressure on it then provoked the
Palestinians or attempted to provoke the
pal
Ians into a
war what was called the
1982 Lebanon war sometimes it's called
the first Lebanon
war and at that point the Palestinian
leadership was headquartered mostly
refugees no entirely refugees excuse me
headquartered in
Lebanon Israel launched the war and in
the course of the war Israel killed
roughly 15 to
20,000
Palestinians and
Lebanese
overwhelmingly civilians it's worth
noting for your listeners that actually
the Israeli Death kill
rate back in
1982 was actually much higher than any
of the recent Israeli assaults on Gaza
or any of the recent Israeli conflicts
armed conflicts with its
neighbors after the 1982 War the
Palestinians were
defeated in the course of that war as I
said about
20,000 Palestinian and Israelis were
killed overwhelmingly civilians and the
PLO went into Exile in
Tunis at this point a pal Indians in the
West Bank in Gaza who were under
occupation
realized that nothing is going to happen
externally in order to abet their
aspirations to statehood Independence
self-determination and so in
1987 the Palestinians in Gaza and the
West Bank
went into civil Revolt
overwhelmingly
nonviolent it was called you listeners
who are not old enough to
remember uh it came to be called the
first in i n t f a d
a uh a civil nonviolent civil
Revolt I happened to be there during
that civil Revolt I lived in a
Palestinian Christian village outside
Bethlehem called B Sor and I lived in a
Palestinian refugee camp or right across
the street from a Palestinian refugee
camp uh in Hebron called faar
Camp uh and that first
in Israel exerted a huge amount of
violent
force uh and that too
suffered a
defeat and that defeat climaxed in what
came to be called the oo Accord so your
listeners I think at this point I've
gotten the key uh dates and numbers
they'll remember when conversation comes
up UN resolution 181 that's 1947 you on
resolution 242 that's 196 7 and they'll
now remember another term that
constantly comes up namely the Oslo
Accord now under the terms of the Oslo
Accord it was signed between the Israeli
Prime Minister Yak Rabin and the head of
the PLO yaser Arafat and it was presided
over by US President Bill Clinton some
of your listeners and viewers will
recall what's come to be called the
Great h Shake on the White House lawn
when President Clinton is flanked by the
Israeli and Palestinian
leaders the essence of the Oslo Accord
there is a written Accord but then there
is a political
reality uh the Palestinians as a result
of that Accord were not
granted a state or even the right to a
state what they were granted was a
five-year interim period that was to
climax in
1999 in the course of which some sort of
settlement would be worked out and in
return the Palestinians gave Israel that
full
recognition so as your listeners by now
will I think
gather the
Palestinian was responsibility under UN
resolution
242 was fulfilled to allow Palestinians
to exercise their right of
self-determination and statehood in the
20% of Palestine that remained namely
the West Bank including East Jerusalem
and
Gaza well the Palestinians never got
that from
Oslo in fact they didn't get anything
from
Oslo in fact they got the
reverse because in the course of those
years from 1993 on Israel started to
Annex
territories on the in the West Bank by
creating another term which will now
Enlighten your listeners by creating je
uh Jewish settlements
in the West Bank and the sement came to
occupy more and more territory in the
West Bank Israel confiscated more and
more land in the West Bank until about
half of the West
Bank was now under Israeli
control
effectively annexed to
Israel in so nothing came of that Oslo
Accord on the Palestinian
site uh and then in
2000 uh in 2000 September 2000 for
reasons which time will not allow me a
new Uprising occurred in the occupied
Palestinian territories what came to be
called the second in
and uh the second inter father began
just as the first intera in
1987 it was overwhelmingly
nonviolent but Israel
fearful of a second
protracted civil
Revolt akin to the first
in they then exerted maximum amount of
violent Force to repress it uh to use
the cliche to nip it in the bud so just
in the first few days of that second
inata just in the first few
days Israel fired
approximately 1 million rounds of
ammunition to
repress that second nonviolent civil
revolt and God second nonviolent civil
Revolt then quickly spun out of control
and it became quite the violent on both
sides the kill ratio that first three
weeks of the second in father was about
20 Palestinians to East to each Israeli
20 to one as it happened I lived there
at the time not a long period but I was
there
and on one of my visits I did meet with
the then head of uh Hamas his name was
Dr
rentis now I want to be careful my
memory is not perfect on these things so
it's pretty good um I don't know if he
was
the the fhe head or he was one of the
leaders he was eventually assassinated
by the
Israelis on in that event I did meet
with
him as with all of those leaders at the
time I don't want to speak about later a
very simple life very humble guy uh he
would say his kitchen or his home looked
like a what we would say in the United
States a tenement from the N you know
1930s and when I talked to him about the
situation it had already gotten quite
violent um on both sides I do remember
when I asked him about what was going on
I said do you think this is the right
strategy your
strategy and he said to me when the
first intera
began the ratio of Palestinians to
Israelis killed was 20 to
one and then he
said now
it's I think don't get I could be wrong
I try to be very I'm a stickler for
facts I think he said now it's down to
six to
one and I remember thinking at the time
and commenting the Palestinian
friends I I thought to
myself this wasn't really a political
strategy it was
just eye for an eye tooth for a tooth
who was calculating the E
efficacy of the strategy he chose or
Hamas chose just in terms of trying to
establish an
equality not of human life but an
equality of death or
corpses I of course can understand that
uh it's not for no reason that we have
that saying an eye for an eye a tooth
for a tooth a still part of our moral
vocabulary even though many people
repudiate it it still
Rings loudly it resonates for a large
number of
people uh and so I didn't think then it
was oh political it was a kind of moral
calculus in any event Israel once again
exerted
massive death and destruction on the
Palestinians
destroying huge amounts of
land
homes
incarcerating thousands of
Palestinians in
fact uh carrying out a pattern of
systematic
massive torture of Palestinian
detainees somewhere on the order of tens
of thousands were being systematically
and methodically tortured by the Israeli
prison guards and professional
torturers and by 2000
6 2005 we will say the second andata
have been
defeated come
2006 there were elections held in the
West Bank and Gaza Israel had set up in
the occupied Palestinian
territories after
the uh September 199 three oo Accord
they had set up an
Palestinian
administrative government in the
occupied Palestinian territories it were
came to be called the pa the Palestinian
Authority you will recall earlier I
referred to the PLO the Palestine
Liberation
Organization the PO pretty much now
disappeared from the scene and it was
replaced by what came to be called the
Palestinian
Authority and the elections were
held and surprisingly for everybody amas
agreed to participate in the
elections and surprisingly to everybody
they
won because the Palestinian Authority
this administrative unit up by Israel
was very
corrupt and
self-serving and so the
Palestinians hoping for a government
that represented them and not
individuals simply cashing in on new
status
of executors of Israeli policy they came
to be called Israel's
subcontractors uh Hamas
one and that's where the story really
begins which I'll try to bring up to the
present now United States had
urged Palestinians including
Hamas to participate in the
election
but the United States and
Israel were not pleased with the
come former President Jimmy Carter was
in the occupied territories to monitor
the
elections and he pronounced them and now
I'm quoting you completely honest and
fair
elections when you when Hamas
won
Israel immediately
imposed a brutal economic blockade on
Gaza uh that
blockade was
then uh
supported by the United States and the e
e the European
Union Palestinians were never given a
chance Hamas was never given a
chance the moment the results came
in the
screws were
turned in the expect hope and
expectation that the
Palestinians knowing that the screws
would not be
unturned until they disposed of
hamus and
reinstated the Palestinian
Authority Under the control of the
preferred Authority ities of the United
States or the preferred figures of the
United States in fact Hillary Clinton at
the time she was the senator from New
York she said we made a big
mistake by not rigging the election
that's what she said we made a big
mistake by not rigging the
election wow so the palestin were now
faced with a brutal blockade Gaza is
five miles
wide and 25 miles
long or at least it was that until
today when it seems it's going to be cut
in half again without get to you get to
that in a moment what does five miles by
25 miles mean
I'll just give you my personal mental
image of what that means I jog five
miles along the Cony Island Seashore
every morning so it's the distance a
person uh nearing 70 he jogs in the
morning at the
beach what's the length of
Gaza it's less than a marathon a
marathon is 26 .2 miles and God say or
yeah five it's about the size of
marathon uh
guysa just a little less uh and in that
territory there are 2.1 million people
or
2.2 that's some give or take on the
action number uh that makes
Gaza among the most densely populated
places on God's
Earth it's more populated than
Tokyo I don't want to anticipate too
much yeah now Israel says it's going to
take control of the northern half of
Gaza which means among the most densely
populated places on God's Earth will now
be
twice as densely
populated uh after the current blood
leing uh nobody is allowed nobody for 20
years nobody with the rarest of
exceptions nobody was allowed
in and nobody was allowed
out so for for the purposes of today's
conversation it
means most of those
Palestinians who cck through the gates
of Gaza it was their first time ever
leaving
Gaza they were in their 20s it had never
seen
anything except via the web he had never
seen anything of the outside world they
had been confined to this
space for 20 years that's not
hyperbole that's not
exaggeration about half of Gaza half the
population for the past 20 years has
been
unemployed that figure or that
percentage Rises to
60% on when you look at the
youth so now your audience should
Ponder here is a
population
where a large
part has been left for 20
years to just
Pace back and
forth in an area that's among the
bestest most densely popular in the
world with
nothing whatsoever
else to look forward
to that's the fact you get up each
morning there's no
work there's nowhere to go you can't
even try your look immigrating see what
happens come to the United States come
to France no C
Le that's why David
tamaran the former British
conservative prime
minister he described
Gaza as an open a
prison where Ru
Kimberling a respected
Israeli
sociologist at the Hebrew
University he described
Gaza as the world's
largest concentration camp the largest
concentration
camp ever
the most of the water in
Gaza is
undrinkable
non
uh of
Goa is by International humanitarian
agencies it's labeled
severely strong and
secure
now collect all these
facts with one other
fact every listener should
remember as Israel is now
proceeding to annihilate by their own
admission to annihilate all human life
in the nor all breathing life in the
northern sector of
Gaza that half of Gaza
half comprises
children one half of
Gaza are
children if you can
imagine the
accumulated
rage the accumulated
anger at being
trapped being born
into the largest concentration camp
ever and
then after 20
years they have that
moment where they can exact
revenge on October
27 excuse me October
7 but that's still not the full
picture in
fact as ghastly as that picture
is it doesn't even
begin to touch the surface of the
reality because
periodically Israel
launches these
Hightech massacres on
Gaza
and in the course of
which they kill very large numbers of
civilians in
operation cast
lit
from December
26 2008 to January
2009 they killed about 1300 1,400,000
Palestinians
350 of them
children and
demolished level
flattened 6,000
homes
uh then that was called
operation cast
lead I'll skip a large number of other
operations because time doesn't allow it
I will only
say that try as I
made I can never remember in names of
even
half those
murderous high
tech
destructions visited on
Gaza what Amnesty International call
it's not my title bear in mind after
operation
castled they issued a mammoth report
titled 22 days of death and
destruction in
2014 July August
Israel initiate
operation protect protective
Edge in the course of protective
Edge it
killed about
550 Palestinian
children it
demolished
18,000 the head of the international
Committee of the Red Cross Peter moer is
his name m a r r for those of you
listeners who wanted to check my what
I'm saying now it's the icrc
international Committee of Red Cross
Peter
Mor he went to Gaza after
operation protective Edge as the
Israelis called it and he said quote in
all my
life I have
never witness
destruction on the scale
that I've now observed in
Kasa that's quite a
statement just as Baro
Kimberling describing Gaza as the
largest concentration camp ever is quite
a statement but from a very responsible
sociologist Peter
Mo describing the destruction as the
most
the magnitude of the destruction
remember the job of the president of the
icr is to visit War
zones so he must have visited an awful
lot and he said he had never seen the
magnitude of Destruction in
Gaza which means and here for the first
time for the first time in everything I
just told you I'm happy to present the
documentation for every word I
it I wrote a book called Gaza an inquest
into its
martyrdom which nobody has ever
faulted for
lack of not just
documentation but
voluminous
documentation from reading through
thousands and
thousands and thousands of pages of
Human Rights
reports I started in
1982 it's 40 years later and I don't say
it with pride indeed I say with a little
bit of embarrassment that's all I did
with my life document what happened
there so I'm quite confident that every
claim I just made can be documented not
by one source
but by voluminous
sources with that as a side note let me
get to my one point of
speculation every one of those
youths who crash through the gates of
Gaza I would
bet every dollar I owe every
dollar that everyone because they knew
they weren't going to come
back there was nowhere to hide in
Israel even if they
managed to escape they were going to be
tracked down they knew that Daniel was
going to be their last day on God's
Earth and the night
before they left
Gaza I would guess
everyone of them kiss their mother
goodbye kiss their father
goodbye and inside of them inside of
them they
vow to
Revenge not
only the life of
misery Agony anguish and
torment that they
experienced from the day of their birth
because they were born into that
concentration
camp but they also
vowed to
Revenge the death of their brother their
sister their niece their
nephew all those
persons who
perished whose bodies were
incinerated mangled and
destroyed during
Israel's
operations as they like to call it in
gosip so and this is where I'll leave
off and my
shocked by what happened on October
7th I cannot say I
was I
cannot I was shocked by the
Ingenuity displayed by the people of
gazu gazu was probably the most
surveilled place on Earth Israel has a
very sophisticated not just
external security system but also
internal there are many collaborators
with Israel inside Gaza
many and that the people of Gaza eluded
it it's very impressive you know
Israelis are now stunned how could that
have
happened so that part surprised
me however
even as I was surprised don't I don't
want to claim to be any kind of
Clairvoyant I was surprised by the
magnitude of the deaths yes for
sure was I surprised on
reflection at the
Vengeance that
Inspire those killings no I can't say so
and I will leave you with one last
thought and then you take over because
I've taken more than probably what might
call be called a generous amount of time
I want to be clear about
this I hope your program has a wide
reach and we have a time you know an
opportunity to discuss things these
things I'm going to just tell you
something personal which I've not said
to anybody this is a very hard week for
me I'm good at assembling
effects I'm good at putting them in a
logical coherent
order I can't
say I have the greatest moral judgment
it's not bad but moral judgment is like
any other faculty requires study
reflection you know it means knowing the
whole of moral
philosophy and I'm not competent in that
area and most of my adult life I was a
kind of you might call acolyte disciple
of N
chsky I think it's fair to say he was
for 40 years a very close friend of
mine for reasons which I can't get into
now he wasn't
available for moral judgment not the
facts the facts I feel confident about
but the moral judgment how does one if I
can use the Expression position oneself
morally
in light of what happened October 7th I
really didn't know I was very confused
when people asked me how are you doing I
would say well physically I'm very tired
but morally I'm much more tired I'm
struggling with it
so I went back to American history I
went back to American
history I wanted to see what was just
briefly for your listeners because I
don't know how uh America whether it's
an American audience or an international
audience so in the American context we
had slave
revolts and the slave revolts were quite
bloody so for example the best known
slave revolt in the US or the largest
was Nat Turner in
1831 the Nat Turner
Rebellion now Nat Turner was a relig he
black obviously he was a religious stic
he was a zealot he was convinced that
this rebellion was inspired by God and
all of his actions were sanctioned
approved by God he gave the order to his
Confederates to kill all white people
kill all white people in your
path
and a lot of white people were killed
scores of white white people were killed
by current terminology would call them
Innocents were
killed I wanted to know how did the
abolitionists those who oppose
slavery what kind of moral judgment did
they render on that
Turner and so I went back one of the
greatest of the abolitionists white was
a fellow named uh Garrison William lloy
Garrison he was the editor of a
newspaper called The
Liberator and I want to see what did he
write and I have to say to me have to
say to you it was very consoling to me
because he did what I did after
Gaza number
one he said I told you
so we warned you and warned you and
warned you and warned you we meaning the
abolitionists this was going to
happen number
two he denounced all the Hypocrites the
pious self-righteous
Hypocrites who
were
denouncing what happened in not Turner's
rebellion and number three and I hope
your listeners will pay close
attention number
three even though he said what happened
J did not Turner Revolt was
horrible it was very
clear he never
once condemned the slave revolt he did
not he did not I posted on my
substack I posted on my Twitter account
the full statement by William Lloyd
Garrison he did
not and the na Turner rebellion and I
describe it to you just a moment ago
quite
accurately it now occupies an honored
place in American history it
does and William Lloyd Garrison
is a revered figure there were three
there were basically William Lloyd
Garrison Charles sner uh uh Fus Stevens
and Garrett Smith there are a few but
he's one of the revered figures of the
Abolitionist Movement to end
slavery
so uh I felt assur even in the absence
of my mentor Professor chsky I felt
confident that I had applyed even though
my moral faculty is not finely
owned I apply the right
judgment in this
situation I've gotten some very
ugly back
backlash uh from people who meant a lot
to me in life
uh
however
I if the judgment is right I won't
Retreat
okay that
was
Heavy let me see if I
can Cobble together some follow-up
questions to
that uh
um I just have a few I think going back
to
1948 um if we go before that was the
idea that Jewish people had originally
been displaced from that area so they
were already entitled to that area in
1948 and that's why the UN ruled to give
them the
56% okay yeah that's a completely fair
question and since I'm speaking before
an audience that she doesn't know much
of the
history uh and is not obliged to it's a
tiny corner of the map uh I will do as
best as I can to answer these what you
would call Elementary questions because
yeah uh people just don't
know Israel stake the claim to
Palestine or I should say the Zionist
movement stake the claim to Palestine on
many grounds one ground was that's the
homeland of the Jewish people from 3,000
or 2,000 years ago another claim was
made that Palestine was basically
empty another claim that was made was
well the people in Palestine they're
Arabs and there are all these other
Arabs all over uh what's called the Arab
world and so it's no big deal to tell
the ones in Palestine to move and make
room for us there were various kinds of
claims when it came before the United
Nations I think it's fair to say that
they which CL climaxed that 1947
resolution 181 I've read the record
closely I would say they didn't really
try to make moral
sense of who had title
or who had the deed to what they were
faced with a practical problem or they
conceived it as a practical problem
there are two substantial populations
living in the same parcel of land it
doesn't seem like these two part these
two populations can live together and so
we're going to divide up the
land now you might ask why was it so
unequally divided especially in light of
the demographic balance at the time as
far as one can
guess uh remember this is after World
War II it's
1947 and there are Jewish refugees in
Europe and so there was some
expectation that a large proportion of
those Jewish refugees
would come to
Palestine and so the land was unequally
divided to accommodate the Jews who
would eventually come to Palestine from
the refugee camps in
Europe that makes sense that answers
that uh and then I think just one more
question so you were you're talking
about missile strikes that have just
been throughout this period of time
um from what you read online this is
what I've read online anyway is that
hamus is hiding their weapons in
civilian areas and that the Israelis are
targeting those areas and the casualties
are because hamus is hiding behind their
civilians so what do you think what are
your thoughts on
that well my answer to that is pretty
simple
I don't think we should believe anything
that Hamas says I don't think we should
believe anything that Israel
says I think because they're obviously
partisan and their claims are worthless
unless they make a claim which is in
legal terms called a claim against
interest that is to say they say
something that doesn't serve their
interest then that claim obviously
carries more value
than a claim that you say with your
interest if you say I didn't steal that
money obviously that claim has no value
if you say well yeah I did steal that
money well that claim does have value so
we make a distinction between evidence
based on interest and evidence against
interest and we attach a lot more value
to evidence against
interest so leaving aside the interested
party
there are a third place we can look and
the place most people normally look is
human rights
organizations we have Israeli human
rights organizations like betel the
Israeli information center for human
rights in the occupied territories we
have Amnesty
International we have Human Rights Watch
and we
had in the past some Israeli reservists
namely those who
fought put out Publications in which
they
documented what was done in Gaza and the
the main organization was called
breaking the silence it was Israeli
soldiers who documented in
reports the horrors they observed in the
course of the Israeli op
operations I should note that most of
those who gave
testimony to the breaking the silence
group they were not peaceniks they were
not leftists they just matter of factly
described yes this is what happened
that's what happened and my
conclusions are based
on and were
reached on the basis of reading those
human rights
reports and right now I haven't looked
at the Gaza book in three years and I
have to now refresh my
memory but my memory is pretty
good uh there is no
evidence that Hamas used
Palestinians as what's called human
Shields there's no evidence
of that what there is voluminous
evidence of is that Israel used
Palestinians as human
shields for that there's a large amount
of
documentation now for those of you
listeners who doubt what I have to say
and I think you should you should always
question authority however however
authoritative The Authority you should
always leave a corner of your mind open
to the
possibility that the authority is either
dishonest or simply
wrong I would simply
recommend uh show me
evidence from the authoritative human
rights
organizations from the authoritative un
investigative bodies that looked at the
evidence show me the evidence that there
was human shielding by Hamas so far as I
know remember I'm lming myself to a
separate category I'm not saying what
Israeli government officials alleged
what the Israeli military alleged what
various
organs that repeat what the Israeli
government and the milit
I say I look at what most people do when
I try to assess the factual situation in
combat zones they look at what reputable
human rights organizations say and there
is so far as I know and I as I said it
went through thousands and thousands and
thousands of pages and years and years
and years of my life um now in four
decades uh going through it there isn't
evidence of that
um what are your thoughts on the Abraham
Accords uh and do you think that matters
and is that a still a possibility or are
those doomed
now I think we should in terms of what's
unfolding now we should try to play them
in the
context as I told you
earlier after Israel's invasion of
Lebanon in
1982 the Palestinian leadership was
forced into
Exile and the Palestinian people were
left to their own devices when I say the
Palestinian people I mean the West Bank
and Gaza they were left to their own
devices and that's from the first into f
began when the Palestinian people
realized there was no one to count on no
one to help us God helps those who help
themselves we have to take our state and
future into our own
hands
now um in the present
situation
the uh
Palestinians realized that what the
United States and Israel were're doing
was trying to create
agreements and settle the
conflict outside them so Saudi Arabia
Bahan the United Arab Emirates they
would all make agreements with
Israel and the
Palestinians in Gaza as well as the West
Bank right now we're focusing on Kasa
would be left to languish and
die so I would say I would
speculate that this
attempt at what's called
normalization between the Arab states
and
Israel was
perceived by
Gins as one more nail in the
coffin that it
meant that the whole quot unquote Israel
Arab
conflict would be
resolved except for the Palestinian
people would be left to
die so I think that
was a
factor in what
happened okay I guess last question then
is
there is there any way forward for peace
or is this going to get a
lot nastier like what do you what do you
see ahead I know you're not a
clairvoyant but for the next 5 years are
things going to get worse or is there
any way to resolve it well right now
we're entering the stage of the third
great
explosion there was the explosion in
1948 about
750,000 Palestinians were expelled
1967 between 3 and
400,000 Palestinians were expelled after
the 1967
war and now about a million or more
Palestinians in Gaza will be expelled
from half of
Gaza that will be annexed to Israel
about half of Gaza as its new quote
unquote the term they use is security
Zone and
probably the international pressure will
become overwhelming on
Egypt to open the border with
Gaza and about half the population will
be forced into Exile
again that's my guess it does not at
this point
seem that the International Community
will stop
Israel from carrying on
its next great explosion the one that's
unfolding now and then the next
item on Israel's agenda
will be a will be to carry out a mass
exposion in the
Westbank of Palestinian
Arabs and
thereby
sell the AR the Palestinian or as they
call it the Arab
problem uh and send the
Palestinians into Exile
again
and do you think so I guess I have one
more
question then I'll let you go I promise
um do do you think the response from
Israel could be warranted from
Hamas bombing them on occasion
throughout this period of time or do you
think it's something
more what happened on October
7th was a slave revolt
and then you have to ask the question
you know after the Nat
Turner the whites went
completely
lad they went
berserk they were on the homicidal
rage killing black people in the South
left and right when you get off the air
it'll be useful for you go look at what
they did to that Turner's Body oh you
you can't even conceive it so then I
tried to
weigh what was the right
response you know not turn said kill all
the
whites and I thought I would look to the
highest moral
authorities that they being the
abolitionists the white abolitionists
who gave over their lives to fighting
slavery they're trying to abolish
slavery you go read what Garrison wrote
I posted on my website posted the whole
article in his magazine called The
Liberator he did he hit
ridicule he he
disgust at all those who attacked Nat
Turner and even he expressed
shock at what
happened you can read the article from
the first word to the last he never con
condemned the Revolt that took a lot of
moral
courage because you could
imagine the abolitionists were not the
most popular guys in town and refusing
to denounce the Revolt though those are
inspiring historical figures who have
been
Vindicated by
history thank you again for coming on my
pleasure and I wish you the
[Music]
best